Salut à tous c'est Pêcheur de trésors.
Aujourd'hui,
Quentin est un transporteur de guêpes.
On va l'enlever
et surtout on est là pour pêcher.
Tu vas arrêter de jouer avec les guêpes
maintenant
et tu vas nous montrer ce que t'as
au bout de ton aimant
Il y a des choses
On est sous un nouveau pont, c'est le premier lancer
Tu as vu le chien ?
Tu as ton os, tu restes sage, c'est bien.
Plein de choses
Il y a un gros truc en dessous
Oh, c'est énorme
Je vois des crustacés pour l'instant et du béton.
Un panneau ?
Ouais je crois un panneau avec du béton
C'est une tradition ici, c'est incroyable.
Ils sont chiant à faire ça
On va le mettre sur le côté
On va déjà le décaler pour qu'il
nous gène moins
et surtout
pour essayer de récupérer l'aimant
Un, deux, trois.
Il y autre chose, regarde
Ouais, c'est possible.
Il y a plein de choses
Il reste les autres objets
C'est une pour pompe à graisse encore.
OK, c'est un bon début.
Il ne sait pas où mettre son os
Oh non !
Ce qu'il faut faire, on détache, on jette la corde et on repêche l'aimant
C'est dangereux ?
Je pense que oui.
Alors là, on a fait une bêtise.
On va essayer de ne pas mourir.
Je n'avais même pas vu le fils
Moi je l'avais vu
On n'a pas 36 solutions.
Il faut jeter bien entre les deux.
Au pire on pêche l'aimant et on tire de l'autre côté
Mince
Que ça dérape
Prend on aimant
C'est dangereux
C'est quand même dangereux...
On devrait déjà éviter avec des gants
mouillés
On pourrait le faire avec un bâton.
On ne tient que le bâton.
Alors là, selon moi,
c'est quand même hyper dangereux
parce que je vais essayer de vous
le zoomer.
Vous voyez un leurre de pêche
qui est planté dans le câble,
donc il y a moyen que le câble soit à nu,
Il faudrait qu'on
essaie de passer un bâton dedans
Pour tirer seulement avec le bâton.
Ok
C'est bon, on peut commencer à pêcher !
Personne n'est mort
Ah ! Un indice.
Là, ça vient d'une moto.
C'est l'arrière d'une moto
Il y a la plaque
Ha oui, c'est le plaque noir, carrément.
Dites moi en commentaire
ce que vous en pensez.
Mais pour moi, c'est une vieille Honda
Sympa
La moto est peut être aussi en dessous
Tu vas la remonter toi ? J'ai un peu la flemme.
On la tire du côté
Cherchons la moto.
On va regarder, j'ai encore des trucs.
Ouais.
Alors qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
Je crois que ça vient d'une enceinte,
surement.
Quelque chose, enfin.
Après le panneau.
C'est un morceau d'échelle
On va aller sur le côté.
Tu vas m'aider
Rasta arrête de faire des trous.
N'essaie pas d'enterrer ton os partout, mange le
J'aime bien le poids
Tu penses que c'est une moto ?
Ouais
Ha oui, d'accord
Ca ne rigole pas
Là on est sur quelque chose de massif,
alors j'espère
que c'est le reste de la moto
On va voir, c'est possible.
Par contre, il va falloir tirer ça.
Ça va être moins cool.
Avec les ronces
C'est très lourd.
On peut treuiller là
On va essayer en tirant avant
On a décidé d'utiliser le treuil.
On aurait peut être réussi en tirant à deux
Mais on n'a pas envie de se bousiller
le dos. Ce n'est que le début de la journée
En plus c'est parfait pour treuiller ici
Ca doit être une grosse moto.
Pas si grosse...
Il n'y a pas d'essence
Tu le vois ?
Ce n'est pas une moto.
C'est bizarre.
Un, deux, trois
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est mais ça fait du bon poids pour la ferraille.
Ça je le sais
Oh mais c'est un coffre !
On dirait un coffre fort
Un coffre fort sur pied.
C'est une première !
OK, la ronce a enlevé le cache de ma GoPro.
Stop, c'est bon
Vous avez le coffre fort ici
Malheureusement, je pense qu'à part
des petites crevettes, y'aura rien dedans,
sauf si on arrive à soulever un peu
ces plaques là.
Et vous avez la marque avec une plaque
La plaque du coffre.
Début 20ᵉ siècle
Le poids qu'il fait est dingue
Je ne sais pas trop si il y a du béton dedans
Ou alors c'est seulement de l'acier
Attend, attend !
Trop tard
Vous l'avez vu, la corde a lâché.
Mais Rasta nous a suggéré
une nouvelle idée.
Ce qu'on va faire maintenant,
c'est qu'on va procéder en deux temps.
On va mettre le treuil dans un premier temps
Pour le soulever jusqu'à ce niveau là.
Et une fois que le coffre fort est remonté
jusqu'à là,
on va l'attacher de l'autre côté
et le finir avec le Peugeot Expert
Finalement on fait l'inverse, on le lève avec le treuil
C'est plus sécurisant de cette façon
C'est très lourd.
Bien joué
Quel boulot ! Il n'était pas facile
On a mi au moins trois quarts d'heure à le sortir
C'était long
Ca en moins dans l'eau
Et ils ont utilisé pour voler celui là.
On défets tout ça
On le met droit et on continue.
Il aime tellement son os qu'il ne veut pas
le manger, il veut le cacher.
J'ai soulevé un truc là.
Un maillot de bain ?
Je l'ai peut être
C'est un jolie poêle à fioul
On en a déjà pêche un il y a très longtemps
Il y a trois ans environ, à Béziers
Bien joué
J'ai un truc
Il était sous le pont
Oh, il y a des bijoux.
Oui, oui, oui.
Il y a pas qu'un peu de bijoux
C'est un filtre ? Ou un pot d'échappement
C'est étrange.
Si vous savez en commentaire, moi ce n'est pas ça qui m'intéresse.
C'est peut être ce qu'il y avait un coffre.
Ça, c'est possible.
Ouah !
Oui, oui.
Ça fait plaisir.
Bon, c'est du fantaisie.
C'est aimanté tu crois ?
Ça, c'est des élastiques.
C'est des scoubidou on dirait
Il y a une bague, regarde
Il y a des bijoux là dessous.
Il y a du toc mais ils ne sont pas forcément aimantés.
Ils ne sont pas tous aimantés
Tu as testé la bague ?
Pas aimantée
Non
Ca venait de sous le pont ?
Ouais
C'est une fleur ?
Oh oui ok,
Sympa aussi, même si c'est surement
du toc, ça fait toujours plaisir.
Celui là, il n'y a que le fermoir qui est aimanté
Peut être de l'argent
C'est possible d'après la couleur
Je vais les mettre de côté
Ah mais ça vient du poêle à fioul !
Mais oui, c'est là dedans
qu'il y a la combustion
C'est beau, mais.
C'est des moules.
Ca c'est un morceau de voiture
Très ancien
Vous l'avez vu,
Il y avait un gros coffre fort
Il reste deux ou trois trucs dans la vase,
mais sinon, globalement,
c'est très propre.
On va passer de l'autre côté du pont,
Je voulais d'abord lancer du côté
Ah non, moi, je veux commencer là.
Sinon on se sépare
Non
Oh non, c'est quoi ça encore ?
Il y a plein de piques
On dirait des morceaux de chaînes
J'ai peur que se soit un morceau de gouttière
L'objet descend ici dans l'eau,
et va là bas, de l'autre côté du pont.
Il manque des bouts.
Oui, c'est bien ça
Mon kinésithérapeute m'a bien dit
d'arrêter de faire ce genre de bêtises.
Le dos droit, le dos droit.
Tu ne peux clairement pas garder le dos droit.
Le dos droit, attention aux postures
Au moins elle ne te gênera plus
C'est pas problématique.
On va la mettre dans l''utilitaire
On va la laisser si ils veulent la réparer.
Elle est à nous maintenant
Tu crois ?
Non
Pêcher c'est pêcher
Tout ce qui est dans l'eau appartient à l'état.
Un morceau de panneau
Il y a que le piquet du panneau
Quentin c'est posté en face.
Maintenant, on va avancer
Il n'y a pas grand chose mais on va tenter une nouvelle technique
On aime bien la faire de temps en temps
On va accrocher nos aimants
ensemble et ratisser en tirant chacun notre tour
Est ce que nos cordes sont assez
longues ?
On va essayer de regarder ce qu'il y a sur les aimants
On n'avait pas assez de corde, je vais un rajouter un peu
Tu peux y aller
Je dois tendre le bras
Il y a un câble,
un cadenas, deux cadenas.
Cadenas cassé,
Un autre cadenas cassé
Un piquet en fer
Il y a quelques trucs
Je ne sais pas trop ce que c'est ça
Si vous savez, dites le en commentaire
Pour ceux qui se demandent,
nos aimants viennent du site Maison De La Détection
Nous on utilise celui ci.
Ça c'est le Barbarian de 1600 kilos.
Donc il a une force de 1600 kilos répartie
sur 360 degrés et je peux vous dire
que c'est du lourd.
Bien sûr, là, ça va lâcher, mais en même
temps, il pèse 200 kilos le coffre.
Et donc voilà.
Si vous souhaitez vous équiper,
vous avez différentes gammes
et vous avez le code promo
PECHEURDETRESORS
qui offre 5% sur toute la boutique,
y compris sur les détecteurs.
Regardez Rasta comme il est adorable
et comme il a validé
cette offre en promotion,
Attention de ne pas te faire écraser dessous
Bien joué.
Voilà, le monstre est debout
Il est quand même assez grand.
On ne se rend pas compte du poids
Même avec le vent il ne bougera pas
On a changé de spot, on
c'est un peu décalé.
Ici, on est proche de la cité
ou on a retrouvé plein de choses.
Les vidéos s'affichent un peu partout,
Je rigole, on peut pas faire ça
les vidéos sans description.
La même ville. Bref, aller ça monte.
Un morceau d'enceinte
Un classique
Protoxyde d'azote
C'est quand même rempli ici.
Gaz hilarant aussi
Je ne sais plus ce que c'est ça
J'ai déjà vu.
Baptiste !
J'ai besoin de toi
Il y a du lourd là
Une moto peut être
A deux ca devrait venir
J'espère parce que pour treuiller ici, ce
n'est pas facile.
Mais ça vient, oui ça vient.
Le poids est correct.
Ah oui, d'accord.
C'est cool
Il n'est pas très vieux celui là
Un essieu de petite voiture.
Ah ouais, c'est vrai que c'est
une petite voiture
Je ne sais pas laquelle, dites nous en commentaire.
Il n'est pas vieux vu l'état des câbles.
Ouais, c'est vrai
C'est top pour le ferrailleur
En plus c'est facile à transporter
Celle là est plus grosse que les autres
Mais c'est quoi ça ?
C'est un meuble ?
Ouais ouais, y a du cuivre
plein de cuivre là.
Une petite pince à linge
Un crochet avec
C'est sympa ça
Eh ben ils s'en font des petits ballons de gaz hilarant ici
On est vraiment sur un coin où il y a que du protoxyde d'azote
Avec des petites plaquettes, comme tout à l'heure
Un bijou !
Et franchement, il est pas mal
Il est cassé
C'était un collier
avec un gros pendentif.
Il tombe en miettes un peu
Mais il n'est pas mal.
Ah ouais, sympa
Il a accroché à un endroit où
il y avait pas mal de choses il me semble.
Peut être que ça vient
d'un coffre où d'un sac
On va les mettre là pour l'instant.
C'était dans le coin des bijoux
Eh ben, c'est pas des bijoux.
Ouais !
Encore une enceinte
Il n'y a que des aimants en fait dans ce canal.
Regarde
Peut être que quelqu'un pêchait avec
J'ai pêché
Ah non je n'ai pas pêché
Ah si, j'ai pêché
On ne les comptes même plus
Encore un alternateur ?
J'ai l'impression.
Heureusement qu'on a quelqu'un qui nous les reprends maintenant.
L'alternateur ou le protoxyde d'azote ?
Un bijou !
Ah, je n'avais pas vu ça
Moi, j'ai vu le couteau Laguiole
Avec la fameuse abeille.
C'est un vrai.
Il n'y a plus de bois par contre
Une petite bague avec des brillants
C'est un très beau lancer ça.
Ca c'est quoi ?
Avec un ressort à l'intérieur
Le couteau on voit bien que c'est un vrai, il est un peu tordu
Ca reste de la très bonne qualité
qualité. 440.
Ah oui, il faisait tire-bouchon aussi
très bien ça.
Franchement, je vois le truc.
Je vois une bouteille de protoxyde d'azote j'étais déçu
Bravo.
Un sac ?
C'est un sac
Une bombonne pour taguer
Neutralisant d'odeur
Une brosse ?
D'accord
Etonnant
Et avec ça une pince.
Et là dedans, dans cette pochette ?
C'est vide
Etonnant.
Étonnante trouvaille.
Je crois que j'ai un moulinet.
Regarde ce moulinet.
Il tourne encore
Le retour du pot d'échappement maudit
Pour la pente tu vas moins rigoler
Tu ne veux pas qu'on le fasse à deux ?
Voilà, c'est la fin de la journée.
On est fatigué
On a bien travaillé
Maxi coffre fort, pot d'échappement,
protoxyde et surtout quelques bijoux.
Mais bon, je pense que c'est du toc,
mais on va regarder.
Peut être pas tous.
Même le couteau, hein ?
Une fois restaurée, ça vaut un petit billet
Voilà et nous on se dit à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant
T'es mignon, c'est bien.
T'es un beau chien
On va regarder ce qu'on a ensemble.
On va voir ça.
il s'en fiche, il s'en fiche